Comment ça va ?
Waouh si j'avais su un jour que c'est trois ans de gym auraient servi à faire une entrée en roue et ben j'aurais fait 6 ans et pas 3
Les amis on a tous cette personne qui nous a mis au monde qui a souffert le martyre pendant des secondes des minutes des heures
ou des jours pour les plus malchanceuses et ça vous ne devriez jamais l'oublier. Cette personne n'a plus donné d'amour pour vous qu'à n'importe
qui d'autre dans sa vie
et cette personne c'est votre maman. Je suis désolé ça s'est mal passé entre vous et votre mère je voulais vraiment pas vous mettre mal avec cette intro.
Il y en a eu des embrouilles des conflits parce qu'elle vous a privé de sorties ou d'écrans ou de World Of Warcraft
alors que votre guide vous attendait pour faire le dernier raid et loutter l'équipement le plus fort du jeu et non je ne parle pas
de vécu. Les amis nous sommes aujourd'hui sur
Mother
Simulator nous allons apprendre à gérer un bébé. Chui très curieux car je n'ai que 22 ans, je suis très loin d'imaginer ce que c'est
que d'avoir un enfant j'avais le choix entre demander des conseils à Mcfly et Carlito ou jouer à ce jeu. J'ai préféré jouer à ce
jeu. D'ailleurs bravo Mcfly
deuxième enfant il a eu un fils bravo beau gosse
Let's go.
Bienvenue
dans Mother Simulator. Vous devrez traverser une série de tests difficiles pour prouver que vous êtes la meilleure mère (ou père) sur la planète
il s'agira pour chaque test d'une série d'épreuves qui devront être accomplies aussi vite que possible. Attend gros, moi j'ai juste une expérience avec Natsu vieux c'est pas un humain hein.
Bon je vais faire ce que jeux peux hein. Select challeng e premièrement rencontre le bébé. Oooh regardez il est mignooooooooooooooooooooooooo
ooooooooo
oooooon..
Ah....Attend quoi ?? Mais gros mais c'est une course ça va pas qu'est ce que je fais
il veut quoi ? Il veut une tétine ? Ah mon dieu il est hideux OK tétine tient
baise la main de ton seigneur fils de attend pleures pas pleures pas bébé j'arrive je vais trouver la je vais trouver la tétine oui
comment je la prends ok je l'ai tiens mets la dans la bouche et fermes la yes
pourquoi t'es vénère gros mais pourquoi tu pleures gros je t'ai donné la tétine mais tiens mais fils deup putain  t'es comme ton père enculé
à il me fait peur mec non no fake il me fait peur je l'ai pris sans faire exprès je veux pas j'te pose là
attends j'te pose comment je te pose au pardon merde pardon pardon pardon tiens tiens mes toi là tiens la tétine
vite vite j'ai plus qu'une seconde
mais pourquoi il pense à une tétine je lui mets la tétine dans la bouche il me la crache au visage
quel est cet enfant du démon ok j'ai pas lu les instructions mais bon il fallait laver la tétine putain
je savais pas moi je savais pas gros
natsu il a pas de il a pas de tétine vieux ok il faut que j'ouvre le robinet et que je lave la tétine
alors tiens t'es content
voilà fils deup pardon on s'est donné des challenges a notre enfant c'est magnifique on dirait que votre enfant robot a fait pipi
notre couche waterproof ultra absorbante et résistante au feu devrait vous aider à résoudre ce problème alors on y va putain
enfant du démon va!!!
ça me stresse ça à chaque fois alors il la la couche je la prends haaa ça pue elle pue la poubelle
ah j'ai niqué le sol je suis
Vénère non mais c'est un sketch gros je mais de la pisse dans tout l'appart ah ok ok j'ai compris j'ai compris il fallait de je fasse ça
fait ok c'est un panier de basket
Yes et ensuite il faut une couche elle est ou la couche neuf la y'en a plein oui voilà
Mais qu'est-ce qui va pas
ah faut que je lui mette du talc sur son petit cul vite on a 30 secondes viens là viens là viens là tu va aller là-dessus
mais non mais vas pas dans le tiroir à couches fils deup tu vas aller là dessus mais putain
Vous en faites pas ça va aller très vite ok la couche hop ça dégage yes c'est pas grave ok le bébé
c'est normal ç'est pour gagné du temps vous en faite pas il va bien y faut que je lui nettoie le cul
faut que je lui nettoie le cul je te nettoie le cul
Voilà c'est hyper bizarre ce que je fait
On va lire les instructions car apparemment on sais pas s'occuper d'un enfant !!
alors alors alors si la couche à des fuites jaune il faut la changer
c'est ce qu'on appelle de l'urine bien sûr le bébé n'aime pas rester
mouillé asperges ses fesses avec du talc alors viens viens là viens là viens là arrête de te plaindre 2 secondes stp ma vie est dure
voilà j'en ai mis mes fait chier putain je veux pas d'enfant vraiment ok c parti la couche
La couche sale va salir les autres couches mais ma vie est un sketch !!!
(Rire...) pardon ok j'y retourne ah alors t'en le cul t'en le cul attend la il y'a son cul y'a son cul
c'est bon ok oh la la mais je suis si fort bouya
si certaines filles ont un projet d'enfant n'hésitez pas à m'appeler je serai un très bon père
putain mais grosse c'est dur d'être parent sans déconner
chaque seconde qui passe j'ai un peu plus de respect pour ma maman et mon papa c'est incroyable alors ton bébé a faim
mais il se démerde vieux il va sur alloresto ou livres où ils cassent pas les couilles pour préparer sa nourriture
vous allez avoir besoin d'une petite bouteille d'eau bouillante et d'y ajouter la mixture par contre n'oubliez pas de nettoyer la bouteille
Effectivement ok allez ne soyez voilà on pose on active le on met le biberon dessous pour verser le mélange dans la bouteille
vous avez besoin de mettre cette dernière sur la table puis de prendre la boîte de mixtures dans vos mains et de cliquer sur la
bouteille. Très bien
Mais non mais putain
voilà le biberon est prêt vous en faite pas plus qu'à mettre le bouchon
ok c pas grave c pas grave on va juste nettoyer comme ça il verra pas il est con c'est mon enfant il est con comme moi c sûr
t'as fais quoi là
Voilà  fais moins le malin fais moins le malin maintenant je suis ton père tu me respectes petit con
aller ça dégage ça s'en va loin sa nique sa mère ça
ça me fatigue je vais m'occuper de mon bébé comme il se doit
Je vais pas paix mon enfant est allé en prison
Putain je suis prêt il faut faire un enfant avec moi on y va
oui je lisais un truc la vérité qu'elle est trop souvent il me dit le quart retour à mon âge et comptera deux enfants tu
te rendras compte à quel point ma vie et pas si simple à gérer mais oui oui je m'occupe d'un bébé virtuel et je pète
un cadre déjà mois au ton bébé a sali tellement de couches en voile et aussi vite que possible pour gagner un maximum de points
alors ça je suis pas seul dans la vraie vie en face ce soir allons-y
Papa et les basketteurs alors
l'intoxication alimentaire
vous êtes
empoisonné et maintenant vous devez vous rendre aux toilettes au à gauchy aisne bar qui montre à quel point vous êtes mal voilà temps je
vais y aller maintenant je vais y aller maintenant voilà c'est chaud là
Mais n'importe quoi waouh il ya cabre une foule qui a applaudi
parce que j'ai choisi pour y avancer à chaque fois ma vie c'est formidable oui je dise la vérité
on rigole on s'amuse mais vous verrez que le jour où on sera tous papa ou maman bas on se souviendra de ce jeu et
ça nous servira de ouf
Mais je suis un père voire mountain of gift au putain on dirait bien que votre enfant veut jouer avec ses nombreux jouets préférés
déjà déjà cette fois au moins il aura trois joué pas plus ok je dois lui amener les jouets qui veut c'est ça
oh là là le fils d'homme je dois trouver le jouet armées sarath il
c'est le même joueur voire exemplaire vraiment les parents qui s'en remettent pas trop pour les cadeaux qu'un beau gosse
Putain c'est bleu élus enfants violés vous avez vu comme j'étais excité d'avoir un enfant début de cette vidéo et qu'au bout de 1h à
m'occuper j'ai envie de l'abandonner
Je suis là y'a pas l'option
prêté le bébé aux grands-parents l'abri dans la vraie vie à ce à quoi des parents ils sont sous les toits ils font quoi
mais ils appellent leurs parents eux et ils t'offrent a eu comme ça pendant une semaine allez dis moi que c'est la fin
tremblement de terre non mes mecs alors je fais quoi tout va trembler je veux être comme ça avec lui bros comme un con
C'est pas grave je laisse ça va pas arrêter
mère nature je m'embête à merde prix des étoiles ses lakers aux normes du macabre un tremblement de terre
Je lai je me fiche de vos tremblement de terre mère nature une sucette une tétine bardon alors où est passée cette victime la
danse est un canard battus 5 ha d'ar fils dope attendant
dollar en or mais la droite et il jette et ijet le mois d'août il y est y avait bien sûr vibrato l'inventaire toi fais
partie
n'ont pas joué fair tir que j'achète mes chevaux chiens pendant quatre alimentaire où c'est dur tu veux quoi la couche et je fais la
couche en chef à kaka up le tac le talk le tac le talent
tiens tiens la couche tient au quai bravo papa reviens pas pas vos toilettes j'arrive c'est bon
J'ai des cernes qu'ont poussé pendant la vidéo du mois que c'est fini waouh
vous étiez tellement occupée vous n'avez pas fait attention à la nuit qui arrive à on doit se préparer du café
ok déjà tient jeune chien alors il est où le café ou et le café
ou et le café 1,6 à café il est là pour l'avs la tasse et ensuite on la pose
Je craque putain mais déjà des jardins en 2018 à une espresso là tu fais pas chier avec tes sachiez bordel
à la ferme qui veut un biberon by combien
ben voilà on va lui faire on va lui faire ça peut être si compliqué parce qu'il vient en tout cas c'est que la poudre
a disparu la poudre a disparu fils d'un peu plus de bien là et bien là c'est pour tomber à
vraiment lâche peu plus de nourrir j'en peux plus t'en fais pas c'est pour ton bien mon fils
voilà
Gros je te respecte
je viens de jouer un jeu tu dois m'occuper d'un bébé
je les appelais fils dope c'était très dur sont occupés donc je tenais à t'appeler pour te dire bravo
Pas du tout tu me dis toujours qu'un jour je me rendrai compte de ce que c'est de ton travail au quotidien
en tant que père de famille
Ouais est-ce que tu as dû l'amener à la crèche non
Non
non est-ce que tu avais expliqué que sa famille allait mourir bientôt d'une maladie grave
non puisque ta bulle et expliqué que les dinosaures avaient complètement disparu premier
nom voilà ça c'est leur éducation
Ok
Je veux pas d'enfant
N'hésiter pas a aider pour les sous-titre ;)
PEACE ! X)